what is your because I always get into
arguments I have like two or three
albums that are always rotating as my
greatest album of all time it's Illmatic
or it's doggy style usually one or two
what's your what's your favorite I'm
gonna give the old head answer though
like for me still to this day and even
though I'm from the west coast and all
that to me top to bottom yeah nomadic
yeah yeah it is
yeah yeah it's Illmatic I'm gonna be
honest that that one changed the game I
remember going to the record store and
the dude was in there it was me and my
relative and he was like nah we was like
nah you know nine or ten or something
like that and he's like this is that
[__] you know what I'm saying was like
oh and
never never got old to me I still you
know have you met nausea nah that's
somebody I haven't met I haven't met I
haven't met Nas I haven't met Jay but I
I didn't you know everybody out here you
know I haven't met but uh
you know and we're speaking of the East
Coast like Dipset you know like that was
my [__] so for me and Jim and me and Jim
got a personal relationship because you
know Jim was [__] with the homies
early on certified gangsters he was he
was in that wasn't he yeah yeah he was
in the hood early [__] with foe Ben
rest in peace [__] with hot dog and
and um wacko I just I just randomly saw
that video again like two weeks ago I
don't know popped up on my YouTube and I
was like damn Booyah tribe in there this
[__] was really in concert and
that wasn't like there wasn't people
like didn't come to the hood like that
then in like and Jim was banging so when
Jim came out west like he was tipping
through hoods and like tapping in like
you know what I'm saying and you know
really like similar like I got to give
it up to Waka Flocka too because like
that was around the days when we would
be around sugar like Walker really came
out here and tapped in and when he made
flockavelli he went grab the homies and
put YG hoodie on Brick Squad put ice B
put Joe Moses winning shot hard in the
pain in the jungles you know what I'm
saying I was dope you know what I mean
it's kind of like it's wild to really
think that like
um a lot of the like you know because
back in the 90s you know
the Crips had more of the right right
they were the more popular like if you
think about like yeah dog man that's
already got to know the biggest rapper
in the world is Snoop and the homies
it's like to be honest like Jim Jones
and like Lil Wayne kind of brought
I feel like he kind of attention for
sure to it yeah even though it wasn't
from L.A yeah yeah but it you know what
I mean it was like game Wayne yeah game
for sure too yeah but yeah you know
Wayne and Jim like you know it was It
was a
they was putting on man but yeah shout
outs to gym that's the big bro you know
that when I'm in New York I lived in New
York for like two years I lived in
Harlem so they got that's like New York
really like my second home they they
love me out there I just did a show with
rock sold it out in uh Brooklyn and like
I was like damn that was really like
giving it up Lord Jamar came up to me
and he was like I don't know you I never
done nothing but I watched your setting
that [__] was dope you know what I'm
saying I was like
I'm the type of flowers I need these are
the ones you want they add them the ones
I want you feel me